when you were growing up as a kid a lot
of time ago deep south right right
where'd you grow up in Mississippi
Mississippi mm-hmm
lots of racism lots of lots of stuff to
put up with were you chased a lot as a
kid is that where you got your great
running speed I know I was not chased a
lot as a kid but I knew about racism and
I know how to deal with it what do you
mean you learned it early oh yeah well
because you know n-word thrown at you a
lot I'm sorry the n-word was it thrown
at you a lot when I used to hear you did
yes by the Legman
yeah yeah but I I never let that stop me
from achieving what I wanted to do and I
wanted to play professional football but
you didn't want to play football you got
into out balls how playing hooky you're
Trent you were bad I was a bad boy and
they may be forced you to play football
uh well after I got disciplined then I
the principal wanted me to go out for
the football team and I went out and
gave it a try and just were you great
right away
no not at all when you were how old were
you when you started playing football I
I think I was around 16 you're 16 years
old and your great speed hadn't come out
yet
no how was you didn't run track didn't
do any of that other stuff I was a nerd
oh you know I was just a nerd off to
myself so you try out for the team and
it wasn't like the principal knew
something about you he was just trying
to get you off this no he just noticed
yeah he does notice I could run fast but
but the principal puts you in this thing
you're probably belligerent at first you
don't want to play football
you get on the team you somehow make the
team you must have been scared out of
your mind if you're a nerd you got big
guys chasing you and and and you can get
hurt well I felt out of my element
because that's a nerd I was off to
myself all of a sudden I had to become a
team player and I worked at it and I put
that extra and I was able to become a
starter right away did they know that
you would should be a wide receiver was
that your first position late why
receiver and I played defensive back
what about catching the ball physically
I always had big humongous hands were
you good at it right away uh not I
wouldn't say I was good at it but I I
had that that little extra so when you
start to become a star where people
don't think of you as a nerd but you are
the man
when I became a starter I noticed the
females they started looking at me in a
different direction when you say we're
nerd you'd never gotten girls you'd
never gotten laid that's right you know
I was uh you know until I was 18 18 you
got laid
yeah 18 because at 18 you start to get
ring up in the newspapers yeah I guess I
you know like you said I was the star I
was so sorry and I did your family
because you come from a poor family do
they start to go mmm this could be our
ticket out of here no she's no one Khan
Howard to be honest with you I felt if I
made it to the pros I could do a lot for
my family and so the first thing I
wanted to do when I signed with the
Niners I bought my mom a house when you
say you bought your mother a house that
means I to me that your parents are
divorced no my my father is deceased now
he's deceased yeah when you bought the
house for your mother was your father
dead yeah no he was alive and my father
got a chance to really come to so many
ballgames but he was the type of guy he
was the tough guy he was never the type
of guys to say I love you and you like
you knew that he did did you love him oh
yeah of course I did you did yeah were
you I'm very close with my you know my
brothers my sisters everybody I felt you
were angry in your career with Deion
Sanders true or false
well again Deion and I we we were very
competitive and he was he was the flashy
the flamboyant you know type of
defensive back and yes I wanted to get
up in the skin you are a class act
everyone says I try to be a classic and
in fact the matter is that Deion Sanders
went ahead and signed with another team
and he flaunted things and this pisses
you off so yeah because I think football
is a total team sport and you know Deion
came to us he did some great things on
the football field he was an excellent
corner and he helped us to win a Super
Bowl
but everyone made it seem like it was
all about Deion but you were angry with
him too that he signed with another team
after that he should have stayed with
your team and you should have gone on to
win another shot I would
I would love to have gone on to win
another Super Bowl it was all about
winning so did you confront him did you
say to him listen [ __ ] I don't like
you do you curse by the way I've never
heard you occurs yes I'm a very I can
curse I can say very profound words
would you ever call him a bad name not
on radio I knew well when he went to the
Cowboys I knew it was gonna be a big
time robbery you know all over again and
and I think so many people connect it
because they wanted to see us do back
and and I was able to win some of those
battles